have you uh take take me back as
somebody who had high interest in
comedy High interest in music how dope
was it like
was there uh when the double XL cover
came out with Dave Chappelle Dead Prez I
want to say Kanye was on there teleport
he was on there
he did such a good job of bringing the
Two Worlds together with the Chappelle
show and just I just think of that in
the block party and just it was amazing
like like for you like how how it you
know important was that as an
up-and-coming comedian who's also
obviously an artist like
he did such a good job I think of I
really feel like he successfully
bridged like two eras of comedy and
music together definitely man it's just
how he he brings people together with
his shows and and and performances
uh it's been cool to to really watch I
snuck into a Chappelle Show years back
when I was
in Chicago I think it was 0-4005 when
he's doing stand-up yeah at the height
of Chappelle Show Congress Theater and I
didn't have money for a ticket I tried
to and it was I was just started I've
tried to like go in I'm like I'm a
comedian they're like that doesn't no
one cares nobody cares and so I just
started looking around the building just
found an Open Door got in and got in and
uh
so it was did I was wild and then the
you know years later do a lot of shows
with him uh it made it super surreal
like damn I used to sneak in your [__]
he's super cool too yeah I got really
high with him once uh it was actually a
core Days album release party
it was me Dave Chappelle
and uh
the guy who played Steve Urkel
Julio Julia Julia white yeah and I was
like
this is intro like what is happening
right now yeah man someone told me as a
12 year old that'd be in a [__] joint
circle with Dave Chappelle and Steve her
I had a Steve Urkel toy as a kid like I
pull this did I do that like yeah it's
crazy man life is made up man stuff be
happening yeah uh when do you plan on
putting out this this album man
July July targeting July 21st
um
and then
looking to do I'm doing sobs June 14th
hey that's a big deal for any up and
coming hip-hop artist to do an SOB show
I'm I'm hyped about it man just you know
I've I've performed there years back 10
years ago [__] with uh
uh with chance actually I just stand up
for a chance massive rap 2013. yeah
um I just celebrated that birthday of
that so shout out to chance
and so I'm yeah I'm hyped to do sobs man
they're headliner yeah headline I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do the you know stand
up and music set so I do stand up at the
beginning
special guests and stuff and who's
opening for you a comedian or an artist
uh
I think I'm gonna have one comedian one
artist uh
maybe a couple artists
probably have my guy highlight Supreme
this dope singer he produced one of my
track knee brace and uh to sell the
track Paradox uh on my project and so
he's amazing performer he actually he
give me little tips in the studio where
he'll say Hey you gotta smile right
you're recording they can hear it they
can hear it through the mic they can
hear it through the mic and so I'll do a
take and be sounding and some I'll be
doing a take and then it'll sound flat
and then I'll read I'll re-cut and and
smile and it sound completely different
than you think that's true yeah that's
somewhere I mean that's like the little
[__] like that yeah you gotta you kind
of know from being in the studio so much
if you just he'll he'll stand in front
of you like hey man
you like doing warm-up [__] and so it's
always just tough to learn from folks
it's always something to to learn from
and and improve as far as the studio and
the show man
um so yeah it's gonna be and I'm I'm the
show gonna be on on point SOB's
Wednesday SOB's June 14th you're gonna
do anything in L.A
I'll do some uh I'm trying to do the
Moroccan it might be in the fall when
I'm in La I don't have anything set but
I'll do something in La soon probably
around the album drop better be dope
yeah
um I always wonder like with the you
know we always hear about like how it's
a little harder to do certain jokes
nowadays because people get offended
yeah I think a lot of that's a little
blown out of proportion but you know it
we are in a much more sensitive climate
a much more divisive climate right do
you think it's a lot harder for
stand-up comedians nowadays
I can't speak to it like for real in the
moment you know because I'm not living
it in the same way even like two or
three years ago like you know like I
feel like it's just like
people get I just I feel like people are
all as much as they want to laugh they
also want to get offended nowadays you
gotta do your [__] man you know what I
mean like that ain't gonna really you
know it's always
as many people as if people offended
there's gonna be other people that want
that type of stuff so you just worry
about your show worry about who's there
and and just write and perform to the
best of your ability and instincts and
that's that's the gig